[Applaudissements]
alors qu'ils perdaient ce vous êtes
numéro deux avec votre info quel est
votre avis j'ai été une fois de plus
léger et concertée par des propos de
michel cymes pourquoi n'at-on rien sinon
le pire
cette fois il a parlé il a parlé de vous
et vous attaquer si vous voulez on
regarder si vous voulez je vous donne
mon point de vue après alors on va
rappeler parce que je crois que c'était
dans sur un site voilà que je consulte
très rarement
voilà parce que moi moi j'en veux plus
tôt au site cas michel cymes je vous le
dis on va regarder
michel cymes et interrogés parce que
j'avais dit les trois personnes que je
l'inviterai jamais dans cette émission
j'avais 6 et michel cymes être parce que
c'est vrai que sentons très très mal
avec gilles verdez et mine de rien
gilles verdez vous ne l'aimez pas du
tout frontalement le site une fois en
plus encore voilà ceci kg et moi c'est
il faut le mettre toujours de l'huile
sur le feu ces ripoux ce qu'ils font je
vous le dis à chaque fois qu'il ya un
mec
ils veulent poser sur valérie bénaïm en
fait me disait un truc à dernière fois
sur ce site aux questions des choses
incroyables mais mais ceux cités et les
autres d'ailleurs on peut interviewé
même je sais pas n'importe quel artiste
sur son actualité ça finit toujours par
une question et que pensez-vous de cyril
hanouna toujours mais c'est vrai sur
s'apprête à ce site qui nous lie c'est
un site ont pu ce qui n'est pas du tout
avec nos jolies à chaque fois ils nous
enlèvent cent mille téléspectateurs idée
là bas notre on a fait une faute de
frappe
voilà je crois que c'est pure médias je
sais pas quoi voilà en plus chaque année
ils sont énervés parce que grâce à vous
je gagne le titre de meilleur animateur
sur leur site et salir salies tue parce
que vous votez à chaque fois et vous
l'êtes universel voilà partenaire d'air
t elle mais c'est un partenaire aux
ripoux merci et donc la dent mais c'est
bon merci et non ils ont interrogé
encore michel cymes voilà donc soyez
droit fait du journalisme droit voilà
encore pure médias et après peut-être
qu'on discutera avec vous mais michel
cymes être moi j'en veux même pas c'est
normal qu'on lui pose la question et
après il va pas dire qu'ils nous aiment
puisque l'on a dit qu'on voulait pas
invités ont regardé la réponse de michel
cymes récemment selena moon a présenté
comme l'un de ses pires invité dans
touche pas à mon poste est ce que vous
avez quelque chose à lui répondre on va
annoncer ça comme ça mais je sais ça
fait un choc série donne même des tests
bon là ma première réaction c'est de me
dire que finalement si cyril hanouna me
détestent c'est plutôt très rassurant
est toujours en phase avec lui alors que
je veux pas être fâché avec quelqu'un
que je vois pas à qui je parle pas
finalement c'est une bonne nouvelle ça
je suis rassuré que cyril hanouna
voilà alors moi michel cymes c'est vrai
que je connais pas voilà je n'ai pas du
tout envie de le connaître l'origine de
la brouille
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya aucune origine
demande je n'ai pas assez juge gilles
verdez qu'il a fracassé dans l'émission
il a mal pris il faut cuire des
gonflables michel voilà on dit ce qu'on
pense dans les émissions et je suis
vraiment je briserai jamais les
chroniqueurs et diront toujours ce
qu'ils pensent et gilles verdez
apparemment voilà a dit des choses sur
jv reste ils n'ont pas plus de la même
envoyé un papier pour dire voilà qui ne
l'accepterai plus aucune critique sur
lui michel si tu nous regardes y aura
encore des critiques sur toi on dira
quand ça marche on dira qu'on sert
marche pas mais on dirait un refus--
avait il refusé même pour parler de lui
c'est qu'il est pour nous attarder sur
existe dans le paysage audiovisuel
français donc on continuera à voir les
toits michel que ça te plaise ou non
et tu peux envoyer tous les papiers que
tu veux maintenant moi je trouve lui que
ce n'est pas lui parce que comme vous
dites c'est luis et c'est bien de penser
pour m pure médias j'ai la bannière qui
s'affiche à quoi il n'est pas qu'un 9h10
et même quand tu es pmp devant quotidien
il n'en parle pas et quand quotidien
dans les dix sept quotidiens largement
en tête tftp soul millions de dt vous me
faites penser que c'est eux
je vais virer l'apli on va virer l'appli
est fait en dépression on sait tous que
le premier site média c'est jean marc
morandini voilà merci à eux non mais
c'est moi non plus c'est vrai c'est jean
marc morandini